I'm tired of hearing about Homer kids
like I have to do it so much that my mom
and dad don't don't um look like
sometimes they let me take a break but
not really and why do you think that is
why why is that because they want me to
have a successful school year I mean at
least be honest to your students and
just tell them the truth it's like how
you only have to read 30 minutes and
sometimes it's actually an hour like can
we have homework
can we have homework can we have
homework and it's really annoying
because today everyone is like we have
homework and then you do like it's
Friday there's a homework on Friday
it's not that I'm tired about hearing
but I hear constantly that there's too
much homework or that there's not enough
you know everybody loves your
neighbourhood teacher but no one wants
to call me up to pay us a salary we can
survive